Oh my God Youtubers they finally confirmed
the doing Green Lantern Corps.
Although some like the always plan on doing,
so I'll explain what's going on there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway going
on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Green Lantern comment on this
video like leave the person that you want
them to cast as Hal Jordan and John Stewart
be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
So many questions.
This is so great.
I'm so excited that they're finally doing
this again and it sounds like they're going
to take their time get it right.
So there couple things we know couple things
we don't know.
So just counting down number 10 they call
it lethal weapon in space.
What does that mean.
So if you haven't watch that movie is actually
really good.
It was made by Richard Donner the man behind
the Christopher Reeves Superman the good Christopher
Reeve's Superman films, so this is really
cool history with DC comics.
Geoff John's and Richard Donner goes way beyond
the DC comics films.
But that's kind of another story, Mel Gibson
and Danny Glover's characters are too old
gunslinger type cops who are forced to answer
the call again, so that makes it sound like
the Green Lantern Corps movie is not can it
be a straight up origin story you have to
have elements of the origin like Jason the
Moa said the Aqua man movie will be all about
his history.
And where he's going next.
So is the same thing with the Green Lantern
Corps movie even though based on the lethal
weapon pitch they'll have already been Green
Lantern's for period of time like they'll
be disillusioned grizzled something crazy
will happen though have to answer the call
again, so number nine.
What is that say about the plot because lethal
weapon implies like a certain progression
of character.
It actually bears a little bit of resemblance
in the.
Sinestro arc in the comics so you probably
heard of him or you seen a picture but if
you don't know his back story he's basically
a comrade in arms who turns evil and becomes
one of their greatest villains, their greatest
hero who became their greatest villains so
it is really tragic story but that's kind
of what happens during lethal weapon, so the
big antagonists of the movie turns out to
be someone who used to be one of their comrade.
So it's a very.
Sinestro type story number eight this'll make
you feel little better to they said the story
is from Geoff Johnson to Green Lantern rebirth,
Sinestro Corps war.
He did a lot of great Green Lantern books
the lottery flash books he's kind of the guy
DC comics that came up taking really old characters
that were cool anymore and making them cool
again, so he's doing the exact same thing
right now with DC rebirth who we are now like
full in the era of Geoff John's at DC films,
so number seven.
How is this gonna tie in with the Justice
league movie and the other DC films.
They haven't really said when it's gonna come,
but when you look at the IMDb just reads 2020
IMDb is not the most reliable place for information
like that.
That's probably just a placeholder.
I would expect it to fall sometime near after
the second Justice league film.
So that's 2019.
So 2020 doesn't sound too unrealistic, but
because it's so far out will of already gotten
to Justice league films.
Meaning they'll have formed the have had their
second adventure we may have even seen Darkseid
at that point.
Meaning that the stories are becoming more
galactic in nature.
Providing for the entry point of the Green
Lantern Corps, but that also means, as is
tradition that he'll have introduced the character
before then.
In some sort of cameo or some small seen so
that you're aware of the concept before the
actual movie comes out.
Most people know who Green Lantern is, but
a lot of people probably never read a Green
Lantern, comic book seizures kinda need to
remind the world that hey this is a character
this is what he looks like in this universe
were to be seeing a movie from him in a couple
more years number six just to clarify, this
is not just a Hal Jordan film this is going
to be hell Jordan and John Stewart like I
said lethal weapon in space.
That doesn't mean that they're both gonna
be on the edge of retirement was can be suicidal.
They're not to be exactly like the lethal
weapon characters, but they'll be partners
who are necessarily the best of friends, but
become comrades through their adventure trying
to fight.
Sinestro or whatever big space threat.
There is when you get into the Green Lantern
Corps you start talking about the war of light,
the spectrum of emotions see get pretty crazy
with the types of stories you can tell, so
number five what is a gonna look like.
If you see the guardians of the Galaxy movie
and how different it feels and looks from
the other Earth-based avengers films that's
kind of be the disparity between Green Lantern
Corps and the other Earth-based DC films.
I do think before guardians of the galaxy
was as big a success as it eventually became
people were afraid of doing really weird things
like that in movies like hey can we spend
$150 million on a talking tree and a talking
raccoon will people care about that.
Turns out they will.
So okay is probably safe to do some of the
crazier Green Lantern stuck his long as you
do it right.
So number four what about story arcs will
I think they'll be elements from Emerald Dawn
maybe emerald Dawn to which is show some of
the time that Hal Jordan spent in prison after
he had been parallax.
So emerald Dawn was sort of like a retelling
of his origin story how he became a Green
Lantern.
So you learn about his tutelage under Sinestro
how he learns that.
Sinestro is a hardliner and keeps this iron
fist on his own people of Cora Gahr sinister
was exiled from the Green Lantern Corps because
he's been using fear to oppress his people
when really he said that he's been using it
to protect them so that sets the stage for
him learning about the rest of the emotional
spectrum creating the sin Nastro Corps, there's
rage, greed, fear, willpower, hope, compassion
and love.
So if you've never read it is way too early
for blackest night or brightest day or even
war of light.
I feel like what they'll do is they'll set
the stage for like a very, very distant future
crossover movie with the Justice league, so
they can Exley make the title of the movie
Justice league war of light that I should
be pretty epic movie to go see and like another
six or seven years, but that's the way way
down the road so I think that they're just
laying groundwork for that in order to do
that you have to tell little bit of Green
Lantern's origin story.
Sinestro's origin story let everybody know
who the villains of the heroes are what the
stakes are so they probably mixed and matched
a lot of elements from these really classic
titles to tell you these characters are without
having to hold your hand like you're watching
Sesame Street or some children's program so
it will be a lot of fun.
The lethal weapon just makes me feel like
it will be of a slightly darker tone.
So a more adult version of Green Lantern,
which I feel like we all want number three,
what about crossover characters.
It is gonna be the first Green Lantern Corps
film or the gonna be any other humans in it.
Besides Hal Jordan and John Stewart will probably
have a brief cameo from at least one or two
Justice league members because will 40 scene
two Justice league films so the probably have
a pre-existing relationship the Justice league
will probably know who Hal Jordan and John
Stewart are.
But the whole idea with doing Green Lantern
Corps is that you have all of space to play
with.
So just like guardians of the galaxy isn't
really connected to the Earth-based avengers
films in a really big way.
I think is going to be the same deal with
Green Lantern Corps like will be off in its
own thing.
Even though there is connective tissue number
two when the gonna guess.
So I feel like casting John Stewart is going
to be way easier than casting Hal Jordan because
everybody still remembers Ryan Reynolds.
I'm sure Deadpool is gonna make a whole bunch
more Green Lantern jokes the Deadpool sequel,
but for John Stewart I feel like Idris Elba
would actually crush it especially if Murtaugh
and Riggs style he's seen a lot of shit like
he's been around the block a couple times
is not like a brand-new Green Lantern, but
another been a lot of jokes about Army hammer
potentially being Green Lantern.
They were trolling people on twitter just
a little bit.
I don't think that's the case I don't think
that there casting him is Green Lantern I
think they were just hanging out a little
bit the people freaked out when both Geoff
John's and Joe mansion Nello followed him
on twitter, but I think that was about something
separate.
See you guys can let me know in the comments
do you want to play Hal Jordan and who you
want to play John Stewart my number one thing
though is that we get like a short film like
a five minute introduction sequence or even
10 minutes where they do Gand that's tail
which tells the story of the very early days
of the Green Lantern Corps.
So you learn about the Manhunters learn about
how they chose to harness the power of will
you get this grandsons of history of the galaxy
that so much bigger than the stuff that you
see in Justice league is his huge concept.
It provides the back door for things like
blackest night brightest day and even the
anti-monitor which you know I don't of the
will ever get to them in the movies because
he such a ridiculous character he's ridiculously
overpowered.
But if they ever do crisis on infinite earths
in the movies I think it's more likely they
would turn that into an animated movie, you
guys can let me know.
Do you feel like if they can get Green Lantern
Corps right in have like a really good Justice
league franchise that they'll even try to
do crisis on infinite earth in like seven
or 10 Years Way down the road whole concept
just sounds too crazy for them to even tries
all be okay if they don't.
So there was so much comic book news from
Marvel and DC defenders all kinds of stuff
to drop today I'll try to get through it as
fast as possible I have a defenders behind-the-scenes
teaser video that will post tomorrow morning
along with a breakdown of all the information
that they dumped.
So it's going to be a really awesome weekend
I'll try to get to all the videos out as fast
as possible while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the new wonder
woman trailer learn all about areas.
The God of war and you can click here for
my top 50 characters are going to be in infinity
war.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!